we are addressing the fungal Kingdom and
exploring it has profound impacts on
global human health on agriculture and
food security and on biodiversity so
those sorts of questions we'd like to
get at is it's it's very clear that
fungi are called a cause of devastating
threats to food security worldwide to
human health they're killing over 1.5
million people every year which is more
than malaria and they're also causing
extinctions in real-time of amphibians
for example and bats and so their impact
is clear but we know very little about
where these pathogens have originated
how they evolved these traits that allow
them to cause such devastating impact
how they've evolved resistance to the
therapeutics and the agricultural
fungicides that we use to try to control
them so we brought together a consortium
of individuals who work on plant fungal
pathogens and the risk to agriculture
and food security individuals who work
on fungal pathogens that are decimating
animal populations globally and then
investigators working on human fungal
pathogens both physician-scientists
basic scientists and bioinformatics
genomics experts who are helping reveal
key features and vulnerabilities of
these organisms that we can exploit for
new treatments so I think the most
attractive and enabling aspect of the
CFR model for us is that it allows us to
bring together an extraordinarily
interdisciplinary team so we have
assembled leading experts in really
diverse areas that are in sort of
traditionally disparate disciplines and
so we're able to bring them together
under this sort of unique program to
tackle these global grand challenges
that couldn't be accomplished in any
other means and we're going to explore
sort of where they came from how they've
evolved these traits and leveraged that
kind of insights to develop really new
strategies to port these fungal
pathogens
[Music]
you